there's a lot of ideas under the
umbrella of neuralink
but one of them is to use electrical
signals to stimulate and then
you also record you collect electrical
signals from the brain at a higher and
higher resolution
and you go
implant
surgically
the methods by which you do the
stimulation and the the data collection
so it's possible for the ideas of
optogenetics to play well with this
and then we can even zoom out outside of
just neuralink and just the whole idea
of brain computer interfaces
what are your thoughts
well i think the engineering that
they've done is actually pretty cool so
i i like the uh robots yeah from the
from the design perspective and it
wasn't a it was a design approach that
wasn't being taken in academia
and it's great that they did it and i
think it's it's pretty cool um so i'll
say that
also there are many ways that you can
record from many thousands of neurons
and that's not the only way it's a it's
a very interesting way
we and others are using
brain penetrating electrodes that
actually get quite deep the this whole
structure the brain is very interesting
we there's the surface cortex where it's
the most recently
emergent part of the brain in evolution
mammals have it reptiles have something
a little bit like it but it's not really
the full thing
it's a this is a very recent thing
that's what we can access with some of
these you know like the neurolink
approach and with some of these short
electrodes
this part of the brain the cortex is
only a few millimeters thick there's so
much that's deep though that's so
important there's the striatum there's
the thalamus there are the parts of the
brain that
drive uh motivation that drive hunger
and thirst and and social interaction
and parenting
and
and flight and fear and anxiety all
these things are there's so much that's
deep that these surface approaches are
not getting to and so we and others are
using these very long
electrodes that help us get deep and we
can still record for many cells many
thousands of cells
uh we can have multiple of these at once
in the same animal
and so there's a diversity of methods to
get to this goal um i think it's great
that that people coming from you know
the the
you know outside academia will bring uh
ideas that weren't being worked on uh at
least approaches they may turn out to be
synergistic
these things work very do work very well
with optogenetics because all these
electrical recording methods that's one
channel of information flow light
delivery is a separate you know more or
less independent there can be some some
artifacts that happen but if you're
careful that it's another independent
pathway of information flow
and we've done
really
fun experiments in mice where we play in
patterns of activity with light
and we record activity from all across
the brain of a mouse electrically and so
using optical and electrical together is
extremely powerful so like opto electric
brain computer interfaces
which by the way there's uh efforts on
the computing side to build optoelectric
uh servers so like where you have both
electricity so because optics is really
interesting light is a very interesting
method of communication that's like you
said orthogonal in many ways
it doesn't have some of the constraints
of bandwidth that electricity does going
through wires but
you're able to but it's less ability to
control precisely at scale
so there's challenges and there's
benefits and having those two interplay
is really really really fascinating
especially one obviously on the other
side
of your signal is a biological
mesh
mush
mushy mesh well the the mushy mesh is
kind of interesting because we we have
there are problems with light light
scatters in the brain so that the
photons don't just go you know linearly
through they whenever they hit an
interface between fat and water lipid
and water they
they bounce off in different directions
and so you can come in with all the
resolution you want you could play in an
incredibly detailed
high resolution pattern of light but the
photons start scattering
quite quickly and by the time you've
gone a couple millimeters deep you've
lost almost all that fine spatial
information
so but we've developed workarounds the
longer wavelength light you use if you
get into the infrared there's less
scattering you can use two photon
methods or three proton methods where
the photons have to arrive all together
at the same time
you can put in fiber optics we developed
these fiber optic methods in 2007 where
you can access these deep structures
with fiber optic methods and you can put
many of these fiber optics at the same
time in an animal we've used holographic
methods
3d holograms to play in
hundreds of individual cell sized spots
of light and we can and we can change
those quickly and so there are a lot of
tricks a lot of interesting optics
engineering that has come together with
neuroscience in a pretty exciting way
you